scrutin nom masculin désignant les
opérations qui constitue une élection la
tête du scrutin dépend de l'élection à
laquelle il correspond un peu comme
votre tête
de quoi de l'humeur de votre coiffeur
techniquement c'est pourtant simple
un bulletin dans une urne une signature
sur le registre et hop le tour est joué
mais un scrutin peut-être uninominal
plurinominal majoritaire et ou
proportionnelle bref un scrutin peut
parfois prendre des allures de
choucroutes capillaires une belle tête
de vainqueur pour une élection
municipale
le mode de scrutin dépend du nombre
d'habitants dans la caune dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants il
est majoritaire plurinominal à deux
tours un candidat est élu dès qu'il a
obtenu la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés représentant au moins un quart
des inscrits pour les sièges restant 2e
passage ou pas quel champion pour les
électeurs pour les communes de plus de
1000 habitants
c'est la nouveauté il s'agit d'un
scrutin proportionnel de liste à deux
tours avec prime majoritaire
si c'est pas du bigoudic compétition ça
seules les listes ayant obtenu au moins
10% des suffrages au premier tour
peuvent se présenter au deuxième et au
deuxième tour la liste en tête
si si c'est drôle remporte la majorité
des sièges
il reste de la bombe de laque est
attribué à toutes les autres disques
proportionnellement à leurs résultats
autre nouveauté des municipales des
initiateurs pour les clous de plus de
1000 habitants
les candidats à l'intercommunalité
seront élus en même temps que les
conseillers municipaux
le 23 et 30 mars il y en a qui vont
s'arracher